hey welcome to a new project camp update
so we bought this big piece of land and
are prototyping a more sustainable way
of living not sure how it's going to go
but let's see and in the previous video
you could see us building a pizza oven
and finding some local materials to
build something with
and in today's video we're actually
gonna build
a roof
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
so here we have all the wood we got from
the sawmill
however the dimensions are not always
very accurate i noticed
beams should be 15 they're like 14 and a
half 15.2
so it's gonna be a bit of a puzzle
actually to put it all together
have to chop
[Music]
[Music]
okay so turns out because the wood is a
bit thicker it does fit exactly nuts
under the softer
maybe one turning
no still too big
maybe cutting in another improvised way
with a handsaw
like step by step
[Music]
[Music]
okay so here's the problem uh when we
ordered the wood i guess we gave them a
cutting list so i assumed they would cut
it in the right size they didn't do it
they all left them a bit longer
i thought this wouldn't be a big problem
because we have sauce to cut it tony now
i realize that our saws are actually not
big enough to cut the whole way
so with this one it's not possible to
cut and with this one we have this
improvised way the tool to align the
solid we don't really have a proper one
so i use this one but the saw easily
slides on top which makes you go not
very straight
so i think i'm going for this approach
with this saw but i might need to make a
little bit of a
tool
so
[Applause]
[Music]
so after the beams are cutted it's time
to sand them
yeah i will be sanding the beams so that
afterwards we can apply some oil so
we're gonna have a little production
line
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
how's it going rita
[Music]
so we're now almost ready peter is
sending the last one and we've already
been oiling a bit
so after everything is sanded we can go
full-on oiling
[Music]
um
[Music]
let's go
[Music]
do
[Music]
so
[Music]
so now we're gonna cut out a few areas
uh in the beams so they can lean in each
other
and we're gonna do this with a router
so we're gonna take off like two
centimeters here
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so we're now ready taking out all the
wood areas for the connections next i'm
gonna drill the holes
to make sure we can just put in the
screw
and i made a little mold i mean just
very simple from some leftover material
but it saves me measuring
so i'm just going to put it in the right
spot
oh
[Music]
[Music]
what is number four
so we've been treating the wood
mainly with a
linseed oil
which is very natural
but these guys will be digged down and
they will be needing an extra boost so
we have this guy here
which is also somewhat an oil
seems
quite more chemical
therefore a bit more resistant and we
will just put on the down part with this
oil
so we have some sort of foundation for
our new shader for the oven
we put we don't want to use cement or
concrete or anything so what we've done
is to put a
piece of
galvanized pipe where we are going to
put our beams then in the bottom of this
pipe is going to be
some rough ties broken roof tiles from
the worst piece to avoid the wood to
touch straight away the earth
this also protects the wood from the
earth
and gives a bit of a strength to all the
structure
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so the foundations are now in place roof
tiles are in wood is cut it
so
now it's time to assemble everything got
a few big screws
it's a bit challenging because it's a
lot of heavy wood with just three people
so we need to see a little bit how we're
gonna put it all together and lift up
the beams
so it should be good exercise
[Applause]
[Music]
is it straight
very straight
[Music]
all right so the structure is ready next
we're gonna put on the beams so we can
connect roof tiles
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
it's lunchtime
brunch time
[Music]
so this is our first test
it's working yeah
what do you mean what does it do
bit of shade
[Music]
they look crazy
[Music]
what's next guys roof tiles
exciting
yeah
i did a lot
there
[Music]
do
[Music]
do
[Music]
so after all the roof tiles were up we
needed to do a bit more leveling
[Music]
do
[Music]
and finally we also add two walls to
avoid wind and create a bit of a cozy
place
[Music]
so
[Music]
and the walls are actually a pretty big
surface area and we didn't oil them yet
so we tried a more effective way of
using the compressor
[Music]
so here's the final result a little
wooden shot
[Music]
made from cedarwood limeseed oil and
local roof tiles
with a pizza oven and space for a table
on the side
a chimney to keep the smoke outside and
a water ditch to collect the water
it provides a shade for the hot sun in
the summer and the cover for the rain in
winter
so we go from this setup
to this
yeah okay i see what you're thinking the
real question is does it actually work
so we now fired up the oven uh made the
dough so now we're ready to bake some
pizzas in a dry structure
[Music]
pizza
thank you
so it's now uh raining
but we can eat pizza dry
of course so that was it for this video
we now have a dry roof to big pictures
on pizza
next week we might actually not have a
video because we're waiting for some
materials to come
but the video that is coming next is
gonna be the last one of this season and
it's gonna be a cool one so make sure to
watch that one update number 40. for now
thanks for watching and see you in the
next update